okay so cecil stedman is one of the most
enigmatic characters in invincible
the government agent seems like a
strategic genius that is always
one step ahead of everyone else and
because of this he's one of season one's
most
interesting characters but what are his
hopes his dreams
well we're not really going to be
discussing that but throughout this
video we will be going over his comic
history
what the show does differently and also
how he got those scores
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
anything ruined then i recommend that
you turn off now
whilst the show might be taking things
in a different direction
we will be discussing what happens with
him mark robot
omniman and the rest of the characters
so get the hell out of here if you still
want some surprises
if you're still here huge thank you for
clicking the video now let's get into
our invincible character breakdown
okay so cecil stedman first appeared in
the pages of brit
called death all the way back in 2003
based at the pentagon he worked
alongside his partner donald
who you two might know from the tv show
though he wouldn't make his appearance
in the invincible universe until issue
13 of the original run
the character has a long and rich
history in the pages of image comics
as a young agent cecil was captured by
terrorists
who ended up torturing him and they also
exposed him to a flesh disintegrating
gas
that completely ravaged his skin luckily
brit
stepped in to save the day and he freed
the character from what would have been
certain death
however cecil's body was badly damaged
and thus he had to have artificial skin
put over his entire skeleton in order to
save his life
however cecil left a scar around his
mouth as a reminder of the time that he
failed
now though on the surface this just
seems like a great bit of character
design
it actually goes beyond that and
certainly hints to readers at exactly
what kind of a man that he is
cecil once said that he would make a
deal with the devil in order to keep the
planet safe
and his entire appearance also speaks to
this mentality
though he seems like a corporate suit
dude due to his attire
there's also an ugliness to him that is
hinted through this score
and as we learn throughout the series
he's someone who will do whatever it
takes to win
even if it means breaking the rules the
previous head of the global defense
agency
once told cecil that he could be the
good guy or the guy who saved the world
but not always both at the same time
this is something that stuck with him
and driven by his ambition cecil quickly
rose through the ranks of national
security
it wasn't too long before he was chosen
to replace the head of the gta after he
stepped down
and for years he worked with groups like
the guardians of the globe
in order to protect the planet from any
invaders now the show version and comic
one
do differ quite a lot in the comics he
doesn't actually appear until after
omniman has revealed the truth to his
son like everyone else on earth he was
completely blindsided by the superman
and wasn't aware anything was up until
it was too late
juxtaposing this cecil in the show is
there quite early on
and he quickly discovers that it was
nolan who killed the guardians of the
globe he launches an investigation to
get to the bottom of things
and very much plays nolan into thinking
that he's not a suspect in their deaths
cecil even exercises damien dark blood
and sends him back to hell
just to keep up appearances whereas in
the comics
this plot point never happened instead
damien simply went away to investigate
the attack
and showed up much later when things
were already out in the open
he was pretty much the butt of a joke as
he showed up like
i know who killed the guardians whilst
everyone was already aware of it
because of his absence early on in the
comics i actually prefer the version of
cecil that we get in the show to the
source material
and you never quite know whether mark
can really trust the guy
now we do learn that cecil knew omniman
for several years
and they actually met early on in
nolan's career he gave cecil the bs
story of veltron that he told everyone
including his son
and though cecil knew it was likely
false he let it slide so that earth had
a protector
he said that the veltromites traveled
through the universe as part of the
world betterment committee
helping planets to also reach this level
of perfection
however the truth was far more sinister
and they would actually send in one of
their forces as a trojan horse that
would weaken a planet's defenses
this is why nolan killed the guardians
as it would allow for his army to invade
earth more easily
upon the veltromite's arrival planets
would have a choice
death or enslavement and thus their bad
bad news
for the people of earth now cecil worked
with nolan over the decades and he very
much gave him jobs to carry out in order
to save the planet
cecil allowed nolan to become a
best-selling author
and he helped him to build a secret
identity the pair would communicate
through an inner ear link up that cecil
gave him
and this allowed him to constantly be in
touch with the character
so that he could perform certain tasks
and jobs now it's through this that
cecil was actually able to listen in on
omniman's confession
to his son mark nolan and mark went
head-to-head after this reveal
and the former bested his son in the
battle however
rather than killing mark he fled into
space and mark was left as one of the
planet's only protectors
because of this cecil quickly swooped in
to make sure that we still had a chance
against any other invaders
who might now want the planet and he
quickly hired mark to carry out jobs for
him
their relationship worked much in the
same way that nolan's did
and cecil would send him out on missions
to keep earth safe
now over a large part of the run the
pair worked together
and cecil protected debbie by keeping
her on the payroll so that she didn't
have to worry about finances
when mark journeyed into space and
discovered that he had a younger
step-brother
cecil also made sure that the child was
tutored and looked after
however as we know he does have a darker
side to him
and in the show we actually see him
studying mark's blood
although this could have been just
carried out as a way to find a weakness
for
omniman if we looked at the comics it
could hint at an upcoming arc
in issue 50 it's revealed that cecil has
been looking for a weakness with a mark
and that he managed to discover one when
he fought his father
it turns out that velcro might actually
susceptible to a high pitched frequency
and believing that he's become a loose
cannon cecil plays this sound
he also ambushes mark with the rihanna
men in order to take him down
and it's one of the biggest twists in
the entire run however
mark gets the upper hand and manages to
win but the pair's relationship
always feels strained from this point
onwards mark being marked though
still does the right thing and works
with the character in order to help the
planet
now cecil's death comes when mark
discovers robot's plan
after cloning rexplode and duplicating
his mind into the body
rudy was slowly driven to believe that
he was the best person to lead the
planet
and he put a plan in place in order to
take over mark told cecil of this
and though cease didn't really believe
this completely he told robot he was
revoking his access to the gta protocols
until he could carry out an
investigation realizing that the jig was
up
robot grabbed cecil in slit his throat
before stomping on his head
killing the character out of nowhere now
this wasn't quite the last time that we
saw him
and there was actually a big reboot in
invincible that came
years and years down the line mark's
consciousness was sent backwards in time
to his younger buddy
however he still retained his memories
from over the years
mark asked the past version of his
father to stop the invasion of earth
and this led to them going head to head
however he tricked his dad into going to
the guardians of the globe headquarters
and there he revealed the truth about
nolan together they managed to defeat
the super villain
avenging their deaths in the alternate
timeline and cecil arrived to take nolan
in
thus the character does live on in
somewhat of an alternate dimension
though mark does sort of reset things in
a lot of ways
however invincible does live on the
multiverse theory
and thus there are possible universes in
which different events occurred
anyway that's the main top and bottom of
cecil's story
and how it happens in the comics
obviously i'd love to hear your thoughts
on the character as well as which
characters you want to see me cover next
comment below and let me know and as a
thank you for interacting with the video
you'll be entered into a prize draw on
the 30th of april in which we're giving
away three copies of zack snyder's
justice league in 4k
all you have to do to be on the chance
of winning is drop a thumbs up
make sure you subscribe with
notifications on and also leave your
thoughts on cecil in the comments below
the winners of last month's competition
are on screen right now so if that's you
then message me on twitter heavyspoilers
if you want something else to watch then
make sure you check out our breakdown of
the latest episode which will be linked
on screen right now
we've gone over the entire thing from
top to bottom so it's definitely worth
checking out if you want to know more
by the way thank you for sitting through
the video i've been poor i'll see you
next time
take care peace